bien sûr le mélenchon lui seul 3 janvier
donc c'est le moment où tous les
astrologues font les prévisions pour
l'année qui commence évidemment
donc on va le faire avec vous aussi
serait une interview elizabeth teissier
mais l'ancien prévisions 2004 est ce que
vous croyez qu'en 2004 laurent fabius va
être de gauche
il est déjà il peut le faire
est ce que en 2004 le gouvernement va
distribuer des éventails au vieux pour
l'été joker ce dernier n est ce que en
2004 les gens vont enfin se rappeler de
votre nom jean luc mélenchon oui et
c'est bien possible mais surtout vrai
qu'ils apprennent à l'écrire avec un e
et non espagnol et voilà melenchon et
glaxo est ce qu'en 2004 the bachelor va
garder son job
alors écoutez cette femme allait
formidable ouais parce que je vais
croiser sur un plateau de télé devant
tout le monde
elle a dit je n'aurais jamais cru que
quelqu'un ait été capable de faire ça
hein elle s'est tournée vers moi je
pensais que j'avais préparé la répartie
du chèque pour le coup elle bec bien
deux droites
elle a dit oh comme il a des beaux yeux
monsieur mélangera ça c'est tout le
monde s'est foutu de moi pendant quinze
ans que j'ai racontée puis servi à rien
fait c'est un peu vrai c'est vrai
j'aimerais si les et bien sa décharge
est pas con bachelot finalement tu fais
ton gros con comme ça mais un truc et
c'est comme ça que ça marche
est-ce que tu connais le nom du prochain
invité
le pape jean paul ii reste l'humour on
va le faire
mission de ce
dix mois
qu'elle soit encore à moitié